E
GRIN
THIS MORNWIREEF
ON, CALIFORNIA, WHERE
S W>> ME ED A D SOXED A MAN
PAST YEAR
EFEV
AR PT VENOERLING.
LLA BERNAL
, WE
FOYSW HEIR43-YEAR-OLD WESL ORS
TH TTHO THINGS -- THBEING THE TA
POLIEY SAY TBLERO
OLS MAN SS  TIPS,
YIFI EXACTLY
E G THEY WAY HIS HOUSE, HE  TOTO
NOW WHAT THE MAYOR OUND,G AI THU
STOCKTON, KELINCOLN, IS
F OUCI ELS O WORRY  MAKE S
T WO T THEIRN THEYO TOY ED POPIO
REST A LWITH HE TAKE T THEM
LPG IN THEIFE.
HOL ANCE
ONN THIS MAN I
FIRST SE A.V,
POLICE YING
O NOOW AND DO NOT
A MOTIVE
A S?
>> CAMILLA, THANK YOU.
IS LAW
NYPD POLICE DETECTIVE TORN TYOUN
>>MARA AND, THIS IS E STUFDENTAE
RIT?ILLINGLD
LIVE IFOUND OUT UMEROUS PE KEBAN
KILLEDORN REASON, INUST S A CAS
WAS BR
OOL POLICE
CTGH DAYE VES MAY ALSO PLAY SE S
FEEDBACK FROM COUNH INANY N ALL
THEN THE COMMUNITYON TT RTPLAN,O
SO, YEAH, IS WAS AANIGHTENING C
E SURE THI  EDESTE,FULLY.VE NOW
TA A
ES O
INRMATION.
AKINOF PIECING THE
STUFF TOGETHHOW MUCH
NG ON THE PSHAT
WERE CATOU SEE
THE BAC
ESCI THIS, DHE PATTERN -THAT'S
REASON THAT MIGHT  NUE FORR BIZ
PATTERHAVIORRID ON THE TIPS THAE
BY THE PUBLIS THAT PEOPLE  THIA
TH'RORLI CMBOF
DON'TANCH,
WEARING. TO ADD UPEA CONCENTRATA
KNS  OTHER PARTHIS, TOO, QUITE
A HALL OF 2HIBE
GOG >>DER IF